[Music]
on this Saturday night the miracle
rescues and the extraordinary stories of
survival pulled alive after 12 days
buried under Rubble
plus how Aid workers in turkey and Syria
are helping children who lost everyone
the fresh questions about China's
strategy to interfere and sway our
democracy did that panel have access to
these intelligence reports were they
aware of what cesus was aware of we
pressed the public safety minister
arriving illegally why the U.S is
picking up the tab paying for desperate
migrants to come closer to Canada
and picking up the pieces how reclaimed
items from residential schools is
helping Truth and Reconciliation through
ART
global national
for a Nasser
where footage from a rescuer this
morning shows a man's first contact with
the world in 12 days after being stuck
under the rubble the man grabs debris to
lift himself up after barely being able
to move for almost 300 hours and
emotions behind him his wife and child
are also alive starving and dehydrated
he asks for something to drink his wife
and child are also rescued sadly his
child later dies in hospital from
dehydration
good evening and thank you for joining
us 46 000 people are now known to have
died in turkey and Syria in what is now
known as one of the deadliest
earthquakes this Century many are still
missing but as Mackenzie gray reports
there are still rare specs of Hope
it was an early morning miracle
261 hours after the 7.8 magnitude
earthquake rocked turkey and Syria
Mustafa avja was found alive
rush to hospital abja's Rescuers called
his brother
his first question how his mother was
doing his brother responds they're all
okay we're all waiting for you
hours later an introduction avja never
thought would happen his wife shows him
his newborn baby for the first time
I had no hope he said I thought all of
them were dead I didn't make any extra
effort under the rubble as I believe
they were not alive stories like
averages defy the odds most experts
believe 12 days after the Quake there's
little chance more people will be pulled
from under the crushed buildings
somewhere probably between
um you know five to eight days is
probably in a Range where I think that
you would start having some kidney
failure organ failure that could lead to
um unfortunately your death those deaths
unfortunately continue to pile up the
latest one to be found Soccer Star
Christian atsu who was playing in the
Turkish League the Canadian
International's body said to be
repatriated to his hometown the stadiums
atsu used to play in are now tent cities
housing some of the hundreds of
thousands left homeless even in the
countryside the damage is devastating
this Turkish Village nearly split in
half houses leveled after the ground
opened up underneath them
in Toronto volunteers meet at this
Kurdish Community Center phoning back
home to Turkey trying to figure out
who's still alive
erdogan her son Mass holds out hope for
family members but his mother's passed
away my entire family was home during
the earthquake he says almost all of
them were under the rubble this
afternoon Justin Trudeau spoke with the
Turkish president and according to the
prime minister's office should have said
more Aid would be announced soon for
turkey and pledged the Canadian Armed
Forces are on standby to provide
additional support Farah
Mackenzie gray and Ottawa thank you Mac
some of the most vulnerable victims of
the earthquakes or children UNICEF says
between Syria and turkey millions of
them are in need of urgent help
[Music]
volunteers at this humanitarian camp in
adiaman give these kids a rare moment of
joy and normality singing songs to let
them be kids again and to take their
minds at the deep and sudden wounds of
the past 12 days
many are homeless and orphaned pulled
from the rubble to discover that their
family members have died or are missing
experts say the extent of their trauma
is enormous
one of the humanitarian groups that have
been on the ground supporting kids in
turkey and Syria is save the children
and joining us now from gazian tap
turkey is Dan Stewart a spokesperson
with the organization Dan thanks for
joining us I know it's late where you
are you're in your hotel room now but
you know what's going on in the ground
what are you seeing with children
well around 7 million children have been
caught up in the earthquake and it's
aftermath across Northern Syria and
turkey and uh we are incredibly worried
now about the the longer term impact on
these children
um one of the things that we're seeing
at the moment that's particularly
concerning
um is the potential for long-term mental
health impact
um prolonged stress on children can
cause what's uh commonly called toxic
stress which is the worst form of stress
that children can experience and it can
cause long-term developmental uh
challenges and issues with children when
it comes to schooling when it comes to
concentration so it's really vitally
important that we reach children now and
start to provide the emotional support
that they need to recover
um one of the ways that we and our teams
are doing that
um here in Tahir and in Northern Syria
is by providing uh child friendly spaces
which are safe places where our trained
staff look after and support children to
play
talk to each other play games do
activities and just start to be children
and process what they've been through we
had a child in one of our child friendly
spaces this week
um who is between the ages of five and
twelve and during a drawing exercise
um they started to draw uh two dead
bodies that they'd witnessed after the
earthquake and that's clearly you know
horrendously tragic and shows just what
children have been going through but at
the same time drawing really is a
language for young children and it's an
important part of them starting to
express the grief and loss and what
they've been through and start to
process everything so it's vitally
important that we're able uh as like the
children
um to expand what we're doing and reach
more children and to help them recover
yeah it's unfortunate in catastrophes
like this that children are at higher
risk of exploitation even abduction what
are you and other organizations doing to
protect these kids from these threats
yeah it's a it's a real risk um in the
aftermath of a disaster like this when
you know there's so much chaos and so
many uh people have been killed and
injured um the children can get caught
up in it become separated lost alone or
even lose their parents
um so we're working
um in Turkey
um to support the ministry of family and
social Affairs who are leading on family
traits in reunification here so we're
referring children into those existing
mechanisms and in Northern Syria
um let's say the children's partners are
part of a network of humanitarian
organizations who are looking for
children who may have become separated
um finding out what we can about them
and then working with communities to
find extended families or or people that
can look after them because we know that
in most situations
um extended families are are ready and
willing to provide the best possible
care for children who have become
separated or lost their parents it's
such important work that you're doing
Dan really appreciate your time this
late in the evening there Dan Stewart
would save the children
to the war in Ukraine now today U.S vice
president Kamala Harris demanded Justice
be served accusing Russia of committing
crimes against humanity
we have examined the evidence
we know the legal standards
and there is no doubt
these are crimes against humanity
vice president Harris cited attacks in
bucha and the bombing of a theater full
of civilians in mariupal as evidence of
atrocities being committed as this war
plays out and she added the
International Community has both a moral
and strategic interest in pursuing those
crimes
we have breaking news now out of the U.S
where former President Jimmy Carter has
entered hospice care
The Carter Center issued a statement
saying the 98 year old has decided to
receive home hospice care and is
choosing to spend his remaining time
with his family instead of undergoing
additional medical intervention Carter
the country's oldest living former
leader has suffered from recent health
issues including a fight with melanoma
it's been more than two weeks since some
50 train cars derailed in the town of
East Palestine Ohio sparking concern for
the health and safety of its residents
some of whom are now reporting rashes
sore throats nausea and headaches FEMA
the agency that's tasked with responding
to natural disasters and man-made
incidents is only just deploying federal
assistance and that's raising questions
about the government's response Reggie
zucchini has the latest
twisted and burned these derailed train
cars have cast a dark and dangerous
Shadow over this East Ohio Town being
this close to the train derailment I
don't trust it on February 3rd cars
carrying toxic chemicals jumped the
tracks sending a fireball into the air
The Spill has been linked to the deaths
of thousands of animals and health
concerns continue to grow I gotta move
because I'm not safe being here there is
no way we are safe being here the U.S
Environmental Protection Agency says the
air and the water are safe evacuation
orders have been lifted but questions
remain we're going to get to the bottom
of this the White House has not declared
this a disaster because it doesn't meet
the legal requirements meaning FEMA the
agency tasked with disaster relief in
the U.S will only supplement a
multi-agency response we're going to
preemptively file a document with FEMA
to preserve our rights in case we need
their assistance in the future
still FEMA's presence could undercut
comments that East Palestine is safe to
return to we're looking solely at what
would save lives Railways have lobbied
against rules to make trains safer the
trains operator Norfolk Southern
admitted to shareholders in January it's
seen an increase in accidents over the
last four years profits may have
superseded safety recommend stations
many of which are have been on our most
wanted list for decades uh should be
implemented the investigation will
likely look into Legislation during the
Trump Administration laws requiring High
Hazard trains to have electronic breaks
or multiple Crews were rolled back
there's over 4
that somebody needs helps there will be
lawsuits and Congressional hearings
which could prevent a future incident
but might not heal the wounds of the
past
Reggie Global News
a new report out Friday reveals China
trying to sway the outcome of Canada's
2021 federal election the Global Mail
says classified records suggest China
worked to help ensure a liberal minority
Victory the Prime Minister has played
down the report saying Canadians decided
the outcome themselves Mercedes
Stevenson spoke with Canada's Public
Safety Minister on this week's edition
of the West block to find out what the
Liberals knew and what's being done to
safeguard Canada's democracy going
forward Mercedes
for the government is facing renewed
questions about China's attempts to
interfere in Canadian elections the
Liberals have been under pressure to
answer what they knew about attempted
interference and critiqued for failing
to react with more aggressive measures
to prevent meddling leaked intelligence
documents have shown repeated warnings
to the government about beijing's
attempts to influence Canadian democracy
this week on the west block we sit down
with Public Safety Minister Marco
Mendicino to talk about the alleged
Chinese interference in Canada's 2019
and 2021 elections Mendocino was
categoric that the elections were not
marred by China's attempted interference
and that the results were always
determined by Canadians and Canadians
alone but he did acknowledge that
foreign interference poses a serious
threat we've always been upfront with
the fact that there is foreign
interference that we need to be eyes
wide open and Vigilant about they pose a
threat to our Democratic institutions
which is why we put in place tools like
Bill c76 to stop foreign funding from
interfering with elections the Liberals
often point to the election Integrity
panel as proof that there was no
successful interference by China in
Canadian elections and to explain why
the government didn't come out and say
more publicly at the time but it's
unclear if the public servants who sit
on that panel were given access to
highly classified intelligence documents
that laid out top secret concerns about
beijing's activities and strategy I
asked the minister whether the panel had
ever had access to ceaseless
intelligence briefings on China's
actions
did that panel have access to these
intelligence reports were they aware of
what cesus was aware of are non-partisan
professional public servants look at the
information that that they need to to
make the assessment around the Integrity
of the election does that include they
get the they get the access that they
need to the information that is required
to come to those conclusions and those
are important bulwarks against the
threats of foreign interference we'll
have more on that story including
whether Chinese diplomats should be
kicked out of Canada based on the
allegations plus we'll sit down with
Former Defense Minister Peter McKay
about the need for Canada to modernize
its military and protect the Arctic
that's all I had on the show this week
Farah okay Mercedes Stevenson and Ottawa
thank you Mercedes and you can watch the
full interview with Canada's Public
Safety Minister Marco Mendicino tomorrow
on the west block right here on global
the debate over illegal border crossers
tensions rise in Quebec as communities
are overwhelmed by the steady flow of
migrants who paid for their Journey
coming up
the debate is once again raging about
how to help the heavy flow of Asylum
Seekers through Canada's busiest illegal
border crossing
ruxham road is located in Hemingford
Quebec about 50 kilometers south of
Montreal in December alone nearly 5 000
Asylum Seekers crossed into Canada
through the illegal border crossing we
don't know who they are or where they're
all coming from but what we do know is
American authorities are actually paying
for bus tickets to get migrants closer
to roxham Road as Phil Carpenter reports
Quebec's provincial government is urging
Ottawa to find a lasting solution
I don't care the Cubs started lining up
at the Greyhound bus stop in Plattsburgh
at around 2 30 PM as they do almost
daily according to drivers this is just
one wave of migrants to arrive by bus
some on tickets courtesy of New York
City the bus comes at three o'clock in
the afternoon
then it comes again at 6 6 30 in the
evening and that's what you do you sit
here until the bus comes the migrants
come here by bus and other means looking
for a lift to The Unofficial border
crossing at roxham Road a 30 minutes
Drive North of Plattsburgh all headed to
Canada for Asylum like Muhammad Sadiq
naimi about 20 years ago I left
Afghanistan I went to Pakistan turkey
and now I'm in here Canada he and the 20
or so Travelers are among the latest
surge of Asylum Seekers Crossing into
Canada via Roxanne Road according to the
Canadian government the number of people
seeking Refuge who crossed here jumped
to just over 39 000 in 2022 from about 4
000 the previous year it's probably the
Quebec politicians to demand that the
Canadian government do something to stem
the flow of migrants saying the large
numbers is putting a strain on resources
in this province the truth is we cannot
open Boulder to 40
000 people 50 000 people the federal
government says it is in talks with the
us but on Wednesday Quebec Premier
France all legal urge prime minister
Justin Trudeau to discourage migrants
from coming to Canada there could soon
be some relief Quebec immigration
Minister Christine frechette revealed
that of their 125 migrants who entered
Canada via roxham Road on Monday 102
were moved out of Province and that most
of the 380 who crossed over the weekend
372 were also transferred outside Quebec
despite the logistical challenges here
those seeking Refuge like 90 may
continue to choose Canada in large
numbers because it is easy for Asylum
and also this country support the people
also about their Asylum Seekers yes all
the more reasons The Advocates to find
ways to better support them quickly Phil
Carpenter Global News roxham Road New
York
[Music]
ahead could you afford an unexpected
expense new numbers and people tell us
how inflation has changed their rainy
day fund
[Music]
the federal government asks Canadians
how they feel about decades High
inflation and while some of the answers
come as no surprise others are
concerning
data published this week by statistics
Canada shows more than a third of
Canadians found it hard to make ends
meet over the past year is the cost of
everyday essentials a soared nearly half
of respondents said they were worried
about keeping a roof over their heads
young adults women in racialized groups
have especially felt the impacts of
inflation and one in four Canadians said
they cannot afford an unexpected expense
of five hundred dollars so we ask them
Canadians what would happen if they were
footed a bill like that
if I had a 500 expense I couldn't afford
it would definitely set me back for you
know future plans education car payments
inflation hurts very bad because and
just my bike was stalled from here so
now I don't know how I have to buy it
you know I have no money for car but
also I have no money even for bike now
they would just sit on my credit card
yeah it's pretty much it until I have
enough money to pay back decently well
off so I would say that I'm very uh
privileged but I do think that it would
it would take away from some of my other
activities as well it would actually be
a big problem because we're also broke
right now I'm already owing for school
right so that would be a negative impact
on basically my education because I'm
trying to pay off my school then I am
being charged with 500 that's crazy
[Music]
next sewing stories from Canada's
troubling past our residential school
artifacts are telling the truth through
ART
the RCMP are calling in an act of
reconciliation their Heritage Center
Regina is hosting a powerful piece of
indigenous art that bears witness to the
tragic history of Canada's residential
schools Troy Charles has more on the
witness blanket and its mission to
reveal and heal
inside the RCMP Heritage Center the
witness Blanket's presence was felt
immediately well I think to say that
this is
the wooden blanket is the work of
indigenous artists Carrie Newman the son
of a residential school survivor the
Striking Mosaic displays a collection of
over 800 objects reclaimed from
residential schools across every
Province and territory in Canada the
five-week exhibit was officially opened
by residential school survivor Lorna
standing ready of papika Kiss First
Nation
to open up I think he said
how do I do that
I do it with great courage
her words were felt in every corner of
the room in every heart that was present
and she has the courage to recount that
and to relive that every time she talks
about it
just thanked her for that from a brick
fragment to a child's shoe to an Open
Door the piece showcases the destructive
generational effects of the residential
school system the system that stains the
legacy of Canada and the RCMP we hope
that this provides an opportunity for
conversation
and an opportunity for learning the RCMP
helped enforce policies like the Indian
Act which suppressed indigenous peoples
the Heritage Center worked with an elder
advisory committee to respectfully
launch the display the only way we can
really approach reconciliation with any
any truth is to acknowledge the past the
traveling exhibit can be seen on tour
across North America Troy Charles Global
News
and that's global national for this
Saturday night I'm Farah Nasser and we
want to leave you with an update about a
baby who was born under the rubble
Rescuers in Northern Syria found little
Afra with her umbilical cord still
attached to her mother who didn't
survive along with the rest of her
family today she was adopted by her aunt
and uncle who will raise her with their
own newborn born three days after the
quake
until tomorrow take care of yourselves
and each other good night
[Music]